what the [ __ ] is this oh yes he is
speaking of cool products okay have you
tried the new chlamydia dan Bilzerian
screen nitrile chlamydia smoke like dan
Bilzerian and get all the big-ass
[ __ ] boobies you ever wanted in your
[ __ ] life okay yeah that strange
[ __ ] dope yeah what is that is that a
sativa
it's neither its its own [ __ ] brand
you smoke it and get chlamydia instantly
that sounds fire yeah that sounds yeah
it sounds like no although I imagine all
the strains are just infused with dan
Bilzerian pubic hair and then like they
just somehow like create an STD that
he's had from like a model or some [ __ ]
yeah so maybe they just named it after
the model and then they STD oh I see
yeah yeah okay aja Cara is chlamydia
like yeah let me get some of that and
then it's learned that down yeah watch
it's awesome I loved in those Aaron's
brand now yeah dude it's just like
smoked weed if you want to be rich like
yeah he's rebranding weed to be like a
party drug and it's just not yeah not
working for me no it's not working for
me at all now it's so absurd yeah what
he's trying to do like just clearly yeah
you know saying yeah like I just popped
on his Instagram real quick and he's
like like just to see what he's up to
you know yeah just like checking with my
boys well I still follow him from back
then because we're homies he reposted me
one we're definitely boys we're
definitely homies the ghost of Christmas
past yeah that's my guy right there
it's [ __ ] vine yeah this this moment
in your life when Dan Bilzerian posted
this vine yeah you're gonna well we were
at his house 48 yo I remember kids you
want to know how cool your dad was I
remember Danny B that's Danny bills
that's short for Danny Danny bazarian
yeah oh the guy was like playboy like
the guys kind of like the Hugh Hefner
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah the guy that
sells that sex weed the best TV week he
reposted your father yeah no one repost
anymore dad shut up shut up shut up dad
bro we all lip sync
yeah when we're at his house and I like
you look me in the eyes he recognized me
yeah yeah yeah he totally stopped I was
like oh you're that kid I reposted two
years ago really glad to see your
courage working out for you anyways
where you wanted no stairs do you want
to do a DAB you wanna do a nitro dab
downstairs no no that sounds what do you
mean I'm trying to party that sounds
like awful no no I hit this damn hmm hit
this dab I mean fine if these models are
doing I guess I'll dude wait do you
actually follow him no I don't bro his
Snap is so funny is it real or his IG I
was called a snap positioner story kills
me okay
it's like that he's like what inspired
me when I was like I want to do an
Instagram account or was I just like
film me working out like at like insane
hours I just like set like an automated
posting like 3:30 in the morning
seriously yeah it's just like I'm
squatting big-ass weight cuz I like open
up it's fake timestamp yeah like yeah
hers yeah like there's just 405 am a big
wait we thirtyish it's in what shouldn't
what it's like Ronnie Coleman [ __ ] big
ass way ya know it's like I'll let me
swimming through stories then at like
11:30 he's like doing like chest presses
and there's like two girls in the
background and he'll be like exhaling
we'd one of them is putting the dab rig
in his mouth and like no stop trying to
rebrand wheat as anything else but what
it is what's up guys it's your man mega
Chad here wanted to talk about this
brand-new supplement I'm on it's called
marijuana and it's really helping me you
know hit my maxes and blow through them
actually it's really helping me do that
it's like no it's not what do you mean
it makes you want any Funyuns that's all
it is it's weed dude it's not a [ __ ]
party drug dude it's CBD it's is it
actually I sell CBD yeah probably he's
like whatever but now the other funny
part is like he posted this video of his
place I get some big Halloween party and
got all these cuts of like girls like
hitting bongs and [ __ ] I know it's just
not like it's not attractive either
yeah just like bent over like trying to
like drink out of like a tiny drinking
fountain is what it looks like you know
what I mean
they've been sorry this looks like a
science project yeah like the video that
I was talking about when I went on his
Instagram it's like his girlfriend and I
went to his girlfriend's page and her
most recent video was hurt hitting add a
break
yeah and Dan Bilzerian is like doing the
light like lighting it and the caption
was doing dabs with Daddy yep yeah just
looked like it was like the most
complicated he's holding the thing he
like lifts up the chamber and he's like
still lighting the thing and he points
it back in like purges it or whatever
she like inhales three times like friend
like what do you what am I watching
was this a [ __ ] science proj know and
she's like definitely trying to make it
sexy but not sucking on a small dick
he's blown a whistle and I just know
that right after that video she was like
incapacitate yeah there's just no way
she would even be able to speak after
that no doing a dab like that yeah the
one time I I smoked like out of a bong
Taylor one time loads a bong and he puts
like wax on top of it yeah effectively
like it's basically a DAB in my opinion
that's with how strong it was
I thought like you know people talk
about like oh I thought I was gonna die
from wheat that's the only time I ever
like truly felt like I was gonna die
like I felt every heartbeat and I know
that's what all these girls and people
are going through more or less with the
[ __ ] Dan Bilzerian Nitro yeah so just
imagining her be like uh-huh
dad's a dick yeah dan dan my chest she's
looking at she looking around everyone's
clay woloson ground that's like when
like frames are missing from your life
yeah hey hey you want cherry or
strawberry strawberry what your order
your order hey he's here eat it I
thought we were just ordering huh well
Dan my chest out of silicone it's
collapsing onto my arteries the silicone
it's melting Dan the silicone is melting
call 9-1-1 he's like shut the [ __ ]
why did I give you a DAB got something
[Music]